My wish for Women's Month,
I think my wish for Women's Month is looking at the theme,
if I'm right, it's empowered Women,
Empower Women. It's right that this Women's Month that women or oh,
those who identify themselves as women
will be able to help assess or empower other women as well.
My wish,
I hope that people will not underestimate the capabilities of women.
As an educator,
I believe we can make a difference in the lives of the students.
We can inspire them and we can motivate them.
As a communication and media scholar myself
who is also taking leadership position,
I wish that women would have more empowering roles in media.
My wish ironically is for women's man do not just be about women
because for me
it's more of a symbol as to how we should fight for Equality.
We should fight against oppression
and it's not just for favoring women,
but we're fighting as one, uh,
in this world. Uh,
my wish is may every woman find the courage to chase her dreams,
the strength to overcome obstacles
and the wisdom to embrace her true worth and uniqueness.
I wish that every female would recognize their natural
biological ability to connect to their emotions.
My only wish for women like me is to have more time for self care
and also embrace self worth and um,
to have more opportunities for personal development.
Let every woman be the best version of herself.
I think That's the best way of giving justice
in the way we were created by god.
So congratulations to all the women out there
and happy International Women's Month.